I probably seem like a pretty simple guy
ooh
I left over saltines he's covered in
dirt but see I'm much more than meets
the eye I have deep thoughts especially
about technology and bacon
I'm browser that's my mom Johanna Stern
she's a tech columnist at The Wall
Street Journal and this week she gave me
her job because humans have completely
lost it
making smartphone connected gadgets for
friends like me I mean check out my
house I'm living in a freakin Orwellian
nightmare with four Wi-Fi cameras
watching me this crazy trashcan top
thing is a dog gaming console
whatever that means I'm wearing to
activity trackers right now I can't even
eat in peace at first I was going to
treat them like a fire hydrant and pee
all over them but it turns out some are
actually pretty cool I especially love
the Wi-Fi enabled treat dispensing pet
cams one tap on her smartphone and there
were my favorite cookies of course I
like the pricey 380 dollar pet chats
even though it seems to bother mom at
times app looks like dog poop but she
likes it because I like it plus I can
see you around the built-in screen mom
the treats
and I can call her if I press this
button but to be honest I prefer texting
and it doesn't always work the $170
petsy is a good alternative it's easier
to set up it dispenses more treats and
mom likes the app I was pretty upset
when these activity trackers were put on
my collar like I'm on parole or
something the Wonder wolf and whistle
both monitor my levels of activity then
send the info to moms rectangle thing
but then something weird happened I
started going on longer walks and
playing out back more you might have
something to do with the white coat lady
telling them whatever I look good if I
played with one of these high-tech games
all day I'd probably shed a few pounds
to the $300 clever pet is like an Xbox
for dogs I think I'm supposed to tap on
the three pads for food ya know but my
but Archie figured it out in ten minutes
dude it's like the next Steve Jobs
then there's the smart bolt which throws
balls when my mom is really busy and of
course dispenses treats my friends were
really obsessed with getting the streets
especially Wrigley give it up man also
you gotta watch out for the balls just
one of the reasons we prefer a human
throw
technology's great nom but it's all
about playing together I guess at the
end of the day I'm a pretty simple guy
man I'll have toilet paper wonder if
this stuff has Wi-Fi now